madame la Première ministre des millions
de Français sont de nouveau dans la rue
aujourd'hui
rejetant votre réforme inique de
retraite toutes les organisations
syndicales de salariés à l'unisson avec
nos compatriotes ont bien compris que la
réforme que vous proposez malgré les
artifices constituent une régression
unique qui pénalisera chacune et chacun
d'entre eux aucun progrès n'est possible
car votre préalable est de faire
travailler les personnes deux ans de
plus dans quelques heures nous
reprendrons l'examen de votre réforme
par l'article 1er qui supprime les
régimes spéciaux ces régimes spéciaux
qui sont pour nous des régimes pionniers
cependant il y a un régime très très
spécial auquel vous ne vous attaquez pas
c'est celui de la finance c'est le
régime spécial de ceux qui peuvent
cumuler de super contes épargne retraite
évolution d'action gratuites de retrait
de chapeau afin de se constituer une
belle pension de retraite à l'âge où ils
voudront et sans avoir cotisé le moindre
euro madame la Première ministre la
politique des affaires de choix vous
avez fait les vôtres depuis 5 ans vous
dorloter une minorité et faites peser
les efforts sur le plus grand nombre
vous répétez l'opération avec votre
réforme des retraites en demandant à
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt à
ceux qui ont des carrières hachées de
travailler deux ans de plus pendant que
vous refusez toujours toujours de vous
attaquer au revenu financiers qui ne
cesse de croître et qui ne cotise pas
cette fois le sacrifice que vous
demandez au grand nombre et trop
important et les Français ne l'acceptent
pas si vous n'êtes pas prête à épargner
les régimes spéciaux de ceux qui
travaillent pour vous en prendre au
régime très spéciaux au régime très
spéciaux des grands patrons
il ne vous reste qu'une seule option
madame la Première ministre il ne vous
reste qu'une seule option retirée votre
mauvais projet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne
la première ministre avant de vous
répondre je veux à mon tour dire toute
ma solidarité et celle de notre pays
tout entier après le terrible séisme qui
a frappé la Turquie et la Syrie hier
selon un dernier bilan provisoire il
aurait coûté la vie après de 6000
personnes la France est solidaire et
agit comme l'a annoncé le président de
la République les équipes de la sécurité
civile et du centre de crise et de
soutien sont partis pour apporter une
aide d'urgence sur le terrain
monsieur le Président Chassagne avec
votre question vous démontrer ce que
nous disons depuis le début
si demain le système de retraite par
répartition devait s'effondrer si nous
devions passer à la capitalisation ce ne
sont pas les plus riches ni les grands
patrons qui seraient pénalisés ce sont
les travailleurs les salariés les
commerçants les artisans ce sont les
plus modestes et les classes moyennes
toutes celles et ceux à qui une vie de
travail garantit une retraite
alors monsieur le Président Chassaigne
je voulais déjà dit et j'en reste
convaincu nous voulons tous deux
préserver notre système de retraite par
répartition un système qui garantit la
solidarité entre les générations un
système mis en place au lendemain de la
Libération notamment par Ambroise
Croizat ministre communiste du travail
du général de Gaulle
pendant que nous nous battons pour
préserver notre modèle social avec vos
alliés de la nupesse vous refusez la
réalité vous
ignorez la démographie Vous contestez un
fait irréfutable qui n'est pas une
opinion politique le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent baise par rapport au
nombre de retraités alors oui nous
demandons un effort aux Français mais
nous le faisons parce que c'est la seule
façon de préserver notre l'avenir de nos
retraites car si nous nous faisions rien
quelles seraient les conséquences des
hausse d'impôts et de cotisations
massives et nous le voyons dans vos
amendements dans vos amendements qui
pèseraient sur l'emploi et sur les
salaires avec à la clé une montée du
chômage et une baisse du pouvoir d'achat
ou alors nous aurions une baisse
drastique des pensions qui coûterait au
regretté modeste à tous ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et certainement
pas au grand patron plus de chômage et
moins de pouvoir d'achat voilà votre
projet alternatif
c'est le plein emploi et de meilleures
pensions
monsieur le Président Chassagne vous
défendez les régimes spéciaux pour ma
part je crois qu'un chauffeur de bus à
Paris à Vire ou à Clermont-Ferrand doit
avoir les mêmes droits le même métier
doit offrir la même retraite c'est une
question de justice
monsieur le Président Chassaigne je
finirai par un regret sur nos retraites
nous avons eu l'occasion de montrer que
nous étions capables de nous rassembler
notamment en adoptant à l'unanimité vos
propositions de loi pour revaloriser les
pensions des agriculteurs alors où le
débat commence je suis convaincu qu'il
reste des points d'accord à trouver je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons
améliorer ce texte ensemble cela passera
par le débat la confrontation d'idées et
bien sûr le respect les dégradations les
intimidations ça n'est pas la démocratie
aujourd'hui les murs de l'Assemblée
nationale ont été dégradés mais ce sont
parfois vos permanences ou vos domiciles
je veux dire mon plein soutien et celui
du gouvernement aux élus concernés quel
que soit leur parti politique je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
[Applaudissements]